we should think well I feel fair about
this and differ and do it it's normal to
be to feel fair like you'd have to
definitely something mentally wrong you
shouldn't feel fair for every action
there's an equal and opposite reaction
to your question is you know did I kind
of anticipate what would happen over the
last 22 years and Amazon and the answer
is god no want to be happy
build our life not just a business hey
it's Evan Carmichael and this channel is
created to help you overcome the number
one challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you as well you've
got Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn some of the best
lessons from billionaire entrepreneurs
ok let's kick it off with lesson number
one act despite fear with Elon Musk
we're unusually fearless and willing to
go in the face of other people telling
you something that's crazy and I know a
lot of pretty crazy people you still
stand out where does that come from or
how do you think about making a decision
when everyone tells you this is a crazy
idea where do you get the internal
strength to do that I'm office well I'd
say I actually think I feel feel fair
quite strongly so it's not as though I
just have the absence of fear I've I
feel it quite strongly but there are
times when if something is important
enough you believe in it enough that you
do you do it in spite of the fear so
speaking of important things like people
shouldn't think III I should if you
should think well I feel fear about this
and therefore I shouldn't do it it's
normal to be to feel fair like you'd
have to definitely something mentally
wrong you shouldn't feel fair so you
just feel it and let the importance of
it drive you
anyway yeah you know actually we're
something that can be helpful as
fatalism some degree if you just think
it's just accept the probabilities then
that diminishes fear so my starting
SpaceX I thought the odds of success
were less than 10% and I just accepted
that actually probably I would just lose
lose everything but that maybe would
make some progress if we could just move
the ball forward even if we died maybe
some other company could pick up the
baton and move and keep moving it
forward so that were still do some good
yeah same with Tesla I thought your odds
of a car company succeeding were
extremely low
lesson number two get in sync with life
with Oprah Winfrey the first law is the
third law of motion in physics which
says for every action there's an equal
and opposite reaction and we showed that
very beautifully in the color purple
when Missy Lee says to Mister everything
you even try to do to me is already done
to you that is not just a rhetorical
saying that is law that is Newton's
third law of motion in physics which
says everything that goes out is coming
back it's just like everything that goes
up is coming down may take a long time
to come down is coming down everything
that goes out is coming back it's coming
back so to answer the power of
manifestation and meditation what
meditation does is sync you up with the
source what meditation does is allows
you to literally tap into the power that
created you so that you are in alignment
with that and so when you carry that out
into the world everything that you do
comes from the center of that alignment
that's coming from the source that we
call God we call divine energy divine
intelligence whatever name you want to
give it to do we call life when you are
synched up with life life just gives to
you also if you want to have more
confidence check out my 254 series
they're free
the link to join her in the description
below if everything has to work in two
to three years then that limits what you
can do become so skilled so vigilant so
flat-out fantastic at what you do that
your talent cannot be dismissed there
are times when if something is important
enough you believe in it enough but you
do it in spite of fear lesson number
three go step by step with Jeff Bezos so
your question is you know did I kind of
anticipate what would happen over the
last 22 years at Amazon and the answer
is god no so you know Amazon started as
a very small company it was me and a few
other people I was driving all the
packages to the post office myself in my
1987 Chevy Blazer and when I raised
money for Amazon I had to raise a
million dollars which I raised from 22
different investors $50,000 each they
got 20% of the company for for the
million dollars and it was a 40 people
told me no so I did take 60 meetings to
get 20 s's the first question was always
what's the internet and I had to walk
through that and this was 1994 early 95
and so did I anticipate you know fast
forward to today and and the current
version of it no it has been one foot in
front of the other and I think that that
is true for most businesses where you
kind of proceed adaptively its step by
step you figure it out you have a
success and then you kind of double down
on that success and you figure out what
what else you can do what customers want
lesson number four prove your worth with
Jack mop
KFC has refused to hire you so
with all these know-how at the end of
the day what has been the driver which
has made you who you are yeah I wish
people can say yes to me but if they say
yes I have no choice I think accept it
and of course you're not happy when
people say no have a good sleep wake up
try it again
it's always my fault not the other
people spot why you can convince people
if you cannot prove it but the thing is
that very important there are two group
of people you have to convince him first
group people your team they believe in
you they trust in you and they believe
the things we agreed together and second
is your customers they really love your
products and investors it's okay and
lesson number five the last one before a
very special bonus clip is turn failure
into a-plus with Warren Buffett how do
you turn failure into a plus and it's
true when I was in the University of
Nebraska one day I was reading the daily
Nebraskan and it said in room 303
o'clock there will be this panel of
three professors here at the University
and they're going to award the Nathan
gold scholarship I don't know whether
you still you still have been around and
at the time it said it would give you
five hundred dollars to go to the
Graduate School of your choice I don't
know whether it's changing the mountain
but that that was it so I read this and
I went there to this room at three
o'clock that day or whatever it was and
I walked in the room and there were the
professors and I was the only student
that showed up I mean really got to him
I mean anything they were stuck they
they kept waiting and looking at their
watch and hoping maybe more candidates
but there no one came in so I won $500
budget by default and
those are usually my biggest triumphs
when nobody else shows up and so here I
was I had $500 to go toward any it
wasn't it was the limited as any any
graduate school for a master's degree so
I applied to Harvard my dad wanted me to
and i shortly heard from harvard and
they said go to Chicago and meet this
fellow running that who interviews
applicants from the Midwest so I got on
the train and that's what she did in
those days and I spent on 10 hours on
the Burlington going to Chicago then I
transferred to another little inner
urban train to go up to this country day
school where this fellow was the
headmaster and he was the big
interviewer for Harvard and I got there
and after about 10 minutes he he said
better think about something else you
know he come back later on I was I was
19 at the time and I looked about 12 you
know and and I and I acted about 8 it
was not a great combination but so he
said forget it
so I spent cooked a little dinner urban
train back to Chicago and I took the
10-hour train back to Omaha all the time
hey you know what do I tell my parents
you know it's kind of embarrassing but
it was it was the luckiest thing you
ever happened to me I because if I'd
gone to Harvard I would have gone to a
two-year business school I instead
applied to Columbia where I could
graduate in one year and get a masters
degree luckily that by the accident of
it and being in the Nebraska National
Guard which did not get called up for
the Korean War I missed going in the
Korean War I I got to meet Ben Graham
and we had an enormous effect on me
subsequently and I probably got my wife
that way because she was going to
Northwestern and I was able to put on
sort of a full-court press because I got
out in one year and otherwise she didn't
she'd have met some other guy I mean I
got her before the competition showed up
and so it worked out wonderfully it
couldn't
got better and that's been that's been
my life basically I mean it the things
you know you will get some
disappointments you know but the future
is what counts it'd be fun if I knew
every decision I was going to make was
gonna be perfect it would not be as much
fun he liked playing golf and knowing
you're gonna hit a hole-in-one on every
hole you wouldn't play golf if every
time you got out of tea you just took a
swing of the ball ended up in the hole
yeah be fun for a few days you get get
on TV but it the game would not be any
fun so its failure you know and I
wouldn't even consider them failures but
there are mistakes you whatever you want
us to call it they're part of the game
and in the end you know you go on and
and we've made plenty of mistakes in
business we'll make money more and you
know the Babe Ruth and you know for a
long time subsequently we got eclipsed
by a few fellows but he held the record
for strikeouts and also they held the
record for home runs in his eyes play
baseball player until the modern era
came along yeah so it's it's part of the
game if you take big swings you know you
it may you may you're gonna miss some
times now I have a special bonus tip
from Sara Blakely on how to make the
best product that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
which of your failures do you need to
turn into a plus number two what's the
next small step you can take towards
making your dreams happen and number
three what is the action that you're
afraid to take that you need to step
into and if you promise to take action
after watching this video don't just
watch another video you got to do
something after watching it give me a
hash tag believe in the comments and
make that promise to yourself then go
keep it the process of me cutting the
feet out of my pantyhose while trying to
get the prototype made before I launched
it was 2 years so there was a year solid
of me driving in North Carolina on the
weekends and at night or taking time off
from work to go and work on the
prototype get it made I learned so many
things that I didn't know as a consumer
it had never dawned on me you know that
men were making all of our undergarment
so I learned very quickly that the
industry had been taking an average
waistband size between a small and an
extra-large and putting the same
waistband on every pair exactly that's
nice that I said you know that's not
working we're really uncomfortable and
they were doing it to cut cost in
production so I immediately changed that
in a Spanx waistband a size small gets a
small medium gets a medium and so on
makes perfect sense right I also
realized that they had been putting a
tiny rubber cord inside the waist bands
that had been there forever well we had
made so many advancements in yarns that
they no longer needed the rubber cord
but no one had stopped to say do we
still need to put this so I immediately
took the rubber cord out of it and
another thing I learned was the way that
they were doing sizing was just so blew
me away they would figure out his size
by putting them on plastic forms and
they would all put it on a plastic form
they had different size forms and they
would stand back with their clipboards
and go yep that's the size medium and
I'd lean in and I go ask her how she
feels so it's thanks we put our product
on women my mother my grandmother who's
90 my sister-in-law Cassie I mean all of
my friends the girls at spanks we're
testing it on real women and we want to
test it more than two seconds to say yep
that looks like a medium we we have
people wear it for a week wash it tell
us if it rolled did it move did it stay
in place how did you feel very concerned
with Spanx garments and how they made
you feel
if you want more lessons from successful
billionaire entrepreneurs check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
remember if you want to be successful
learn from the other people's mistakes
don't learn from the successful stories
[Music]